all right katie pavlich editor
townhall.com at a fox news contributor
katie good morning to you you know the
story well
uh you also know that probably in
american communities all over the
country they're having similar debates
how do you see this one
they are having similar debates and this
is a culmination of parents over the
past
year year and a half really being
ignored on national level
on the local level they've been fighting
teachers unions to get their kids back
in school
and now they're looking at these school
districts that are requiring little kids
to wear masks all day long despite the
science showing that might not be
necessary there's an interesting study
now out of brown university showing that
actually
mass mandates in schools k-12 schools
don't necessarily stop the spread of
this disease and so they're requiring
kids to do this and yesterday you had a
nurse
on the channel saying look she's she
sees these kids she's in new jersey and
there are injuries being inflicted on
these kids
from wearing masks for eight hours a day
they're getting blisters on their mouth
they're wearing dirty masks they're not
wearing them properly they're not being
switched out
the right way so there are other
consequences for this and to have the
school board allow politicians to take
the time away from the parents
who've been paying for all of this on a
number of different levels
is pretty egregious behavior dr scott
gottlieb had this to say about mass
i think we can do it right around now i
think we should start lifting these
restrictions
as i think we should start lifting these
restrictions as aggressively as we put
them in we need to preserve the
credibility of public health officials
to perhaps re-implement some of these
provisions as we get into next winter if
we
do start seeing outbreaks again i think
the only way to earn public credibility
is to demonstrate that you're willing to
relax these provisions when the
situation improves
uh dr gottlieb has been pretty um
forward-thinking on even at the
beginning of the virus he was like
everyone needs to take this very
seriously and now he's saying
that we're at a point when we can do
this do you think people might listen
i think people are listening i'm not
sure if the people at the cdc
are listening dr fauci for example with
these new cdc guidelines they put out
for
kids to be masked at summer camp when
they're outside and
while they're swimming and how you know
doing all these things that are contrary
to
what we know about the data of how this
disease spreads
outside and among younger children and
so
i think that you're going to see more
frustration from parents more
frustration from regular adults who are
saying look i got vaccinated
or maybe i didn't get vaccinated but we
know that the the disease is going away
and i shouldn't be shamed
or forced to continue acting like we're
in the middle of a pandemic last summer
when things have changed on the ground
so that incentive is certainly something
that
um should be given but the biden
administration hasn't shown any
you know willingness to change the
president wearing a mask
outside that's right i mean we saw them
in plains georgia early in the week with
the carters right
they were inside with them without a
mask took a picture came outside they
were wearing masks
we saw kamala harris on a tarmac early
week with her husband
they're both wearing masks and they kiss
before she gets on board the plane
i mean these confusing signals that it
doesn't encourage people to go ahead and
sign up for the vaccine how's your life
going to change that's what they're
asking
dr mark siegel wall street journal i
think that's a key point
end the mask mandate to spur vaccination
that's the case he makes he writes it's
your responsibility to protect yourself
by getting
your shots he concludes the message to
everyone vaccines work and it's time to
get back to normal so his plea
is to end the mandate on memorial
weekend which would be february
28th i don't know if that's something
president biden would do but it's an
interesting thought
in order to get encouragement out there
well look the federal government and
governments and local school districts
continue to make this argument
that these these restrictions are
necessary because it gives them an
argument on the other side to say what
they need to do in order to
fix the problem whether it's more
government spending or especially among
the teachers unions they want more money
to you know make their their schools
safer as they try to argue
but the bottom line is that the american
people have been very patient they have
been very compliant when it comes to
trying to get through this pandemic in
the right way possible and they have
seen a number of mixed signals
from people like dr fauci from the white
house
from guidelines that were given last
summer about how to move forward with
this and so when dr gottlieb says this
is about credibility
for health officials now it is because
people are saying
well i've done everything i'm supposed
to do and yet i still can't go back to
acting like i'm
i'm in my normal life again despite
doing everything i've been told and so
that is not something that bodes well
for the future
if there were another health crisis in
terms of people listening to
those guidelines since they've been
changed so often
very interesting to hear from those
parents i mean they're fighting for the
kids
that was clear in that video we heard
from sultan thank you katie nice to see
you
have a good friday